The joe rogan experience you are,
you were in space for 166 days.
Amazing.
Huh?
That's insane.
It's,
it's when I sit on my dark and watch the space station go over,
uh,
it's really hard to rationalize cause I know I was up here and I can remember
all the details,
but to try and link in life on earth with,
with seeing that spotlight go across the horizon,
it's,
it's still,
I haven't got sorted out of my head how to connect it.
Is that the longest a person's ever been up there?
No,
we,
there was a Russian guy,
didn't Valarie Poliakoff a state of 14 months straight.
400 and whatever that is days.
Long time.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
I'm nowhere near the record.
That's in the still in 166 days is an incredible amount of time to be detached
from gravity and floating around in space.
What is the effect on your body?
A big effects short term,
huge.
Your body doesn't have to lift the blood up to your head when you're weightless.
Right?
So your whole cardiovascular system changes.
All the nice little mechanisms that squeeze the balloon,
that is your body to get the blood up to your head.
They stop working,
your heart gets smaller.
Uh,
you start losing your skeleton.
Um,
your balanced system completely shuts down.
I mean,
it has no stimulus from gravity anymore.
So you become totally visually based.
So when you come home,
it's brutal.
Building all those things back up again.
Um,
and most of them you feel,
I mean,
you lose the callouses on the bottom of your feet.
It's kind of disgusting because you're sure your feet are like a snake up there.
Over the bottom of your feet are shedding cause you never used the bottom of
your feet and you build up calluses on the top because you're always tucking
your feet underneath things.
So when you come back,
you've even have to grow the callousness back in the bottom of your feet.
And the thing that takes the longest is your skeleton.
Um,
I lost about 8% of the bone across my hips and butt.
It's gone back.
And,
uh,
within about a year of landing all,
hopefully be back to normal one year.
It takes one year for your body to fully recover.
It took about four months before I could run normally again where my body would
get the blood out of my feet and pump it properly back up to my head about four
months,
which is almost as long as I was up in this trip.
But yeah,
the bone takes the longest,
but it's uh,
it's automatic,
which is interesting.
My body got osteoporosis and it's reversing osteoporosis using some internal
stimulus that we don't even understand.
So it makes a pretty good medical study for everybody.
200 years ago,
it was so long ago when you think of like,
if you had to go back in time and live like people live 200 years ago,
it would suck a fat one.
It wouldn't even be a little fun.
Everybody would die.
Every time the flu comes into town,
all your best friends are dead,
dead.
You don't live if you get an infection dead,
you just got to survive at that point.
200 years later,
we're talking about 200 years from now where there's robots that you literally
can't tell if it's a person or a robot.
Right?
For sure.
Right.
100% and no wrinkles.
I think they're already here.
Do you think the robot prostitutes will be the first market?
Oh yeah,
probably right.
Violence or how much?
How much blow back do you think there'll be with robot prostitutes if women,
you know,
what will women like draw a line in the sand?
That fucking robot is a cheating thing.
So back to what you were saying.
So,
so something is ugly as like
they would still get mad if we had sex with it.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
If he gets to like,
if it looks like a fake thing,
women probably,
it would be like treat it like a fleshlight.
Right.
But as it gets closer and closer to a real person,
like if it looks like Robby,
the robot from lost in space,
danger,
he could stick your Dick in that.
No one's going to say anything.
What would they let you print out a face of her though?
Like so if it looks just like your wife,
yeah,
but then you'd be that,
why would you want to come home or faces carving seven inches of calm?
You never clean it.
You just keep shooting on her face.
And she's like,
what are you doing?
You're trying to drown me.
Is this like some passive aggressive shit,
right?
Or you're drowning income or you're married to your Burnett and you come home
and the robot's blonde.
Yeah.
And that's what she just freaks the fuck out.
You come home,
you're putting black face on your role,
your wife.
He's like,
fuck.
I think distract.
The problem that people have with,
uh,
being informed over being distracted is that it's incredibly frustrating and you
feel helpless when you start reading all these stories about the stock market
manipulations about the banks being bailed out and about bail outs where the
fucking people that were involved in the bail out somehow or another warranted
some crazy commission.
They got some bonus of the gut and then the president is going to limit to a
half a million dollars,
like a fucking half a million dollars is a lot of money,
man.
What do you mean you're limiting it to a half a month?
Didn't we just give them a ton of money?
Yeah.
You feel helpless when you read about this shit over and over and over again.
When you watch documentaries on fracking,
when you,
you know,
you read stories in the news about how,
how poorly veterans are being taken care of when they come back from war and
there's so many different things that you read where that doesn't make sense.
I know,
but when you look at all of these new stories,
there's always one underlying issue in every news story.
It's kind of amazing and it always goes back to who is funding these
politicians,
right?
If you get the money out of politics,
that virus,
if you destroy that virus,
things will change quickly because our representatives will be forced to pay
attention to the American people,
the people that are voting for them as opposed to the people who are paying
them.
You know,
if you get rid of that type of bribery that we're dealing with right now,
the entire system needs to be changed
unquestionably.
But how does that ever happen?
I mean,
it doesn't mean we eat.
You have to like get them to change it themselves as well.
How else is it going to get changed?
Well,
here's the thing.
Um,
Congress is obviously very corrupt.
So Congress,
this is congress of America.
They're obviously very much bought by corporations and as a result,
it's really difficult for them to propose any real change.
But when it comes to the state level,
when it comes to state legislators,
it's a little different.
So we actually to get,
I'm a state representative from Texas to propose a regular resolution for a
constitutional convention.
And it goes back to what I was saying earlier about wolf pack.
And if we get,
you know,
state state representatives from all the states to agree to this constitutional
convention,
then we can actually have this constitutional amendment to get money out of
politics.
It's possible.
We just need to inform people about it.
wolf-pack.com
what is the main stream explanation for human sacrifice?
Like what,
what do they believe started off?
Well,
that it's that it's a feeding of psychic energy to supernatural beings.
That's what human sacrifices about that,
that that you take the psychic energy of the individual,
you're going to kill you,
kill them,
take their psychic energy and feed it to these vampire like creatures that are
lying in the beyond that,
that thrive on human misery and pain.
And you know,
who are we to say that such things do not exist?
We don't understand the nature of reality.
I don't go with you on that,
but I do in a way.
I don't believe in demons,
but I do.
I think it's undeniable that there have been massive groups of people that have
participated in horrific things.
So what is that,
if not demonic?
I believe it's,
I believe it's demonic.
I can't prove it.
I can't prove that that's the case.
I just think we should stay open to that possibility that the nature of reality
is so complex and so multilayered that there may be much more going on than we
think and that if we just,
if we just confine our explanations of things to purely economic and material
terms,
we may be missing part of the picture and that when the ancient spoke of angels
and demons to use words,
I'm not saying that I believe in angels or demons as such,
but when they spoke of Lawton light and dark forces,
negative and positive forces playing on the,
on the human race,
maybe they had something going.
Maybe there was something to that.
Well,
I always consider the fact that human beings have this incredibly broad spectrum
of possibility.
It's incredibly broad spectrum of behavior and personality of circumstance,
of genetics and that there's this Yin and Yang of life.
There's this pull and push of life and that the extreme ends of it are good and
evil,
good and evil.
And,
and it's,
it may not be a demon,
but it might as well be a demon if you're marching 80,000 people off the side of
a pyramid and cutting their heart out with a fucking stone tool.
Yeah.
That's demonic.
It might as well being,
might as well be a demon.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that is a,
that is worth considering.
And the A,
and the question is what is,
you know,
what is going on here?
I have a very dear friend called James Tiburon who refers to this world that we
live in as a university of July polity that we have,
um,
that we have lessons to learn from Jew oddity,
maybe dualities,
not the whole thing.
Maybe there is an overarching unity and oneness in,
in all things.
But right now here in this incarnation on planet earth,
we have to learn from duality.
And the thing about [inaudible] is human beings choose.
We can always choose,
even in the most straightened and difficult circumstances,
we can always choose for the light rather than the darkness.
We can always choose for good rather than evil.
We don't have to take that act that causes pain and suffering to another human
being.
We never have to do that.
We can always choose not to.
The alarming thing is that people often will choose the act that causes pain and
suffering to others,
and we are defined by our choices,
and this is where we need to grow up as a species and start to choose,
start to choose the light.
Okay.